hey guys how's it going it's Justine
that's me welcome to ask IJ hashtag ask
i j IJ short for iJustine for those of
you who might not have gathered that
over the past eight years that I've been
doing this show welcome to the first
episode of ask IJ let's get that first
question out of the way what's your
favorite animal question before we get
into the questions I wanted to show you
guys this commercial that I did for
wicks I know you guys have seen a bunch
of other youtubers do these commercials
you may have already seen them running
as pre rules on my video well this is
gonna be an ad inception because there's
probably a pretty good chance that this
ad has run before this video that you
actually watched but some of you have
YouTube friends so you may have never
even actually seen this yet I had so
much fun working on this so I wanted to
show it to you guys you've been tweeting
me pictures of I'm so glad that you guys
have enjoyed it you can check it out I
just seemed calm but first let me show
you the commercial cuz I love how it
turned out and I'm also so excited
because my dear sweet baby Maddy made a
cameo on set hey guys how's it going
today I'm going to show you my awesome
new Wix website it's got everything I
love all in one place oh of course that
means you too Maddy let me show you guys
how I did it I'm gonna get started by
choosing one of these amazing templates
let's just drag it right over here nice
so I make videos and I have hundreds of
them online which is why I'm pretty
excited about this new video gallery of
mine
everything's synced up to my YouTube
channel so you can watch them all right
here let's change the text up a bit now
I want to add some photos they'll all
appear an amazing high resolution which
is super important because everything
has to look professional Instagram
Twitter Facebook chick perfection
everything's got to look great on my
phone phones okay are you ready for the
big reveal
I love it you guys think go to wix.com
and create your stunning website today
so one of the things that was kind of
fun as I did get to bring my dog to set
and it was insane because I was like
okay
Mady is coming in he's right to perform
can everybody make sure that all the
doors are closed to the outside there
was a door that was left open sorry we
forgot there's a through the door that
was left open back here Maddy's outside
okay
[Music]
we could like close that door also is
that possible so I scooped him up
brought it back inside and then he
performed and here he is in the
commercial now wait wait wait wait good
boy good way very good wait so if you
guys want to get your own website check
out Wix calm I'll put a link in the
description and also if you guys want to
check out my new website go to Augustin
calm I've actually been getting
notifications of any time anybody signs
up on my site so it's kind of cool
because I basically have seen real-time
as you guys are accessing the site the
reason that you guys are all here is
because this is an ask a jean episode
and judging by the title we're talking
about the home pod because that's
basically all you guys were asking me
I'm like searching through the ask IJ
hash tag I was like home padang padang
padang padang padang padang but okay you
guys want to know if I'm gonna buy the
home pod and yeah of course who do you
think I am I live and breathe for new
tech especially when it is in the realm
of my sweet sweet apple so the whole
plot will be available in two different
colors there 349 it comes in the white
and the gray it's gonna be really
interesting to see how Siri and the home
pod fits into this whole ecosystem
because it's already been so built out
by all of these other companies we've
got Samsung with Vicks be we've got
Amazon with Alexa we've got Google with
our Google home we've got Windows with
Cortana and if you're a Mac user
obviously Siri is a huge part of our
daily lives whether you like it or not
sometimes I actually hit that freaking
Siri button oh my MacBook and like no it
was an accident
again I don't want to turn her off
because I sometimes actually do use it
so it's a fine line that I've got a walk
with my girl but Apple seems to be
coming into this very very late because
I would be very interested to see people
who are super tech savvy don't already
have one of these things integrated into
their life in some way
whether it's through their TVs or just
the device themselves and that doesn't
even take to account how many people
have so no systems in their house but
now Soto's has alexa integrated into it
now launch the home pod isn't going to
have all of its capabilities available
will people buy the home pod immediately
or will they wait until the software
update actually allows although the
functionality of the home pod should be
having at launch then will they get it
after the update is out but that is one
of the things is yes you have this piece
of technology but with a simple software
update you can expand what it currently
is shipping with I wanted to say to
infinity and beyond both I mean honestly
that I couldn't say it better I mean
that's really what it is I mean the only
limitations are really the hardware
itself so in a long-winded sort of
rambling answer yes I'm getting a home
pod at launch
I think I'll only be getting one until
they unlock the feature where you can
use it in multiple rooms the
functionality isn't hundred percent
there yet but as I said that's a
software update so that will be
something in the future realistically
what I'm thinking that I'll do is that
we'll put one in my office and one
downstairs in my kitchen right next to
my Amazon Alexa mostly because I use the
Alexus show and what I love about the
Alexa show is it has a big screen on it
so every day I walk downstairs I glanced
at Alexa I see what the latest news is
and then I asked her some questions and
what's the weather can you review my
news no I'm actually asking you for news
was I actually I wasn't even talking to
her right now Alexa stop
I completely forgot that I have to Alexa
enable devices up here I have the GE
sole light which is powered by a and I
recently got one of the a spots did I
even answer a question I don't even know
I'm not sure I'm sure some of you guys
are going to ask have I been using my
massive Mophie yeah I have been and this
thing's amazing I've been using it to
charge my drones on the go I use it a
charge my laptop and now I'm just
charging my phone with it yes it's
massive and very heavy I need to plan
accordingly if this is coming with me
Nick wants to know why Adobe Premiere is
the best editing software in the world
forever and he's trolling me he's a
hundred percent rolling because he knows
that I love Final Cut Nick has been
shooting a bunch of videos for me lately
and
knows that this is a lie and I've been
trying to get him on Final Cut for a
very long time and it's gonna happen I
think I should do a video about it and
no actually that would be very funny to
see us going side by side him trying to
edit a video and final cut me trying to
edit one in Premiere but to be fair I
did start editing videos in Premiere
even before I started on Final Cut but
this was a very long time ago that was
back in college so a lot of things have
changed since that jimin wants to know
what is the most favorite video that
I've made it during my 11 years of being
on YouTube and actually this is kind of
crazy because my favorite video that I
ever made was a stop-motion video that I
did in partnership with Google they were
like what kind of video would you like
to make if you can make anything but
would you want to do for the holidays I
was like this is what I want to make
[Music]
no one wants to know if I can tell you
about the movie that I worked on in
Pittsburgh oh you don't even know if I
can tell you guys uh I should probably
ask I shot a whole vlog about it which I
haven't posted yet obviously either but
it was a really fun movie and I had so
much fun being able to be home and
shooting a film in my hometown so
hopefully you guys wait to see that soon
Melissa says what do you suggest if
somebody wants to do YouTube but but is
scared because they think everybody will
make fun of them here's the truth you're
gonna get made fun of you're probably
gonna get made fun of a lot and there's
absolutely nothing you can do about it
you're gonna get made fun of in real
life you're gonna get made fun of online
but you also have to take into account
that there are people who are going to
absolutely adore you they're gonna love
the things that you're gonna do but
they're also gonna have the people that
disagree that's just life like there's
nothing that you can do about it and
once you realize that I'll tell you what
life gets a lot easier you're able to
brush things off weight easier cuz
you're like okay cool you're gonna hate
me well guess what somebody else is not
gonna hate me and even after 11 or 12
years of being online it is making
YouTube videos
it still is crazy to me it's just like
why say anything at all it just it
really just doesn't make sense but then
you do have to think of what is this
person saying and what in their life has
made them get to the point where they
need to hate somebody else for something
that they love no but if you want to
make youtube videos do it find something
that you love make content about it and
the nice people will come eventually
unless you're making hate videos then
you're basically gonna be cultivating an
audience of making hateful content so I
guess to each their own I suppose is
asking why so much hate for Android I'm
not really sure why you're even asking
the question because my secondary phone
is always an Android phone and it has
been for the past question I can't my
first Android phone oh my god it was
like whatever Google first had theirs it
was like the HTC something I don't know
but it's been a long time so since then
I've always had a secondary Android
phone they loved being able to try
different games or apps that may not be
available for the iphone so there's no
hate at all with a constant YouTube
changes what's your best strategy to
remain authentic and avoid burnout and
still evolve with it constant YouTube
changes that's just something that you
have to deal with not only in YouTube
but in life things change and it happens
that if you don't adapt you're gonna get
left behind so it's not easy you just
gotta do it sometimes that's easier said
than done that strategy to remain
authentic
just keep making videos about things
that you love for the past couple of
weeks guess what I haven't felt like
making a cooking video because I totally
burned myself out over Christmas I made
so many cooking videos that guess what
going into your next question to avoid
burnout don't overdo it I overdid it in
Christmas and now the thought of making
a cooking video I'm just like shuddering
at the thought of it but don't worry I
know a lot of you guys want the cooking
videos back so I have seen your cry for
cooking videos and they will be back
I've been planning a couple out and I
think I'm almost ready to film them
again but as far as avoiding burnout it
is inevitable it really really is
because there is gonna be a time really
I can't do this anymore I got to stop
clicking mom's know if you Jetta Matt
Edie and ro we're surrounded
uh-huh no I wouldn't who would survive
okay so here is the order of survival
I'm definitely gone first cuz I'm
completely worthless I'm sure of that
the only thing that I would be able to
bring to this party here I'm an
over-packer I am so prepared for any
situation I've got extra clothes for the
apocalypse
I've even got coffee in my survival bag
amongst many knives and weapons but I
still think I'd probably be the first to
go then Jenna would probably go actually
you know what I think Matt would
probably go first cuz I just realized
that he was in this so it would be Matt
and then me and then Jenna and then
unfortunately it would be ed in row to
duke it out and I know row and I think
that she would probably fight ed to the
desk method to know if I would ever
adopt a little brother dog for Matty or
his sister yes I would I know my sister
really wants to get a dog but it is such
a huge time commitment and I think when
the time is right or when we find the
perfect dog for her we definitely will
get him a brother or sister what do I do
in my free time I'm probably watching
Netflix or sleeping to be honest with
you Jessamyn over my high scores in HQ
trivia I think it's 10 that's not very
good well thank you guys so much for
watching this ask IG episode I apologize
if it was a little bit rambling and all
over the place I feel like I haven't
done one of these for a while so I love
getting a chance to just just gonna say
sit down but I'm standing up so I love
standing up and talking to you guys
so thank you again for all of your
support thank you for watching let me
know if you guys have any other
questions in the comments below and I
will probably see you guys there
so that's it fine
[Music]